see you up next I mopped this well
that's perfect whoa
there we go then we can all have a beer
while we watch your talk yeah beer and
angular testing that sounds fun to me is
that what one of your summary points
[Music]
I did today
yeah pretty much how it rolls huh it's
fun it was really fun putting this I
went and reviewed everything and you're
like so this is how I did do it this is
how we can do it that's how we will do
it for almost everything in here because
it's such a dynamic space at the moment
but it's fun that's cool
to see anything good today
what was the best thing
I'll buy Scott he's awesome me too
yeah it's cool so is he very opinionated
did he say not to do stuff yeah I
haven't seen that one yet so what was he
against
like my feature yeah is that what you're
doing you do by feature or by yeah yeah
it's it's interesting I really like the
new dotnet stuff last he's been really
cool it's all slides but I'm going to
show you some code no you're not going
to see me live code today yeah
today's a lot about the story of what
what are your choices because this
landscape is really changing so I'll
show you what I haven't been doing and
I'll show you how to do it and I'll show
you some choices but really we're not
gonna not gonna bore you with code for
the whole session saying this is how you
do step by step I've got some play by
players I'll point you to UM you just
watch watch a better production version
of that if you want yeah
[Music]
hmm yeah that could be good it's quite a
dark okay good perfect
cool
give it a few more minutes
[Music]
hey Don
good to start all right right hi
everybody welcome to this session on
talking about ionic and in Gerak's and
angular and we're gonna be talking all
about building web and mobile
applications and trying to share as much
code as possible I'm pretty excited to
be here to talk about this I've given
this talk before and I've kind of been
in this space now for the last year and
a half and it's changing but it's it's a
really fun space to be and it's kind of
what I've had a chance to do a whole
bunch of so today someone in the
audience quickly asked are you and me
doing a lot of live coding I'm not going
to be doing any live coding during this
I'm going to show you lots of code but
really what I'm gonna be talking about
is like where wherever we've been and
where are we at and where are we going
and you what are all the choices you
have for sharing code in this specific
space so my name is Duncan I'm a
software architect from Australia I live
in Sydney and I'm pretty lucky for the
last 4 years or so to work for a company
that a consulting company where I pretty
much just did angular 2 all I've done
and on spend half my time on client
sites and writing code and committing
code and I might keep them off for I
might be a serial commuter to their
projects or I might just come in to do a
code review but I'd probably work on
about 12 different angular teams a year
or committing code and then the other
half the time I've been really lucky to
fly around running training of its be
plural side or workshops like I ran for
the two days here and what's really cool
about doing lots of angular and lots of
just one thing is you make lots of
mistakes and you learn from them but you
also get to see all the different things
that other people are doing I've always
come up at ng-conf which was on in Utah
recently which is the main conference
two weeks ago and you kind of get a feel
for where everyone's going and what's
happening and hopefully I can share some
of that stuff today especially around
sharing code because that space is
changing a fair bit so this is kind of
the situation that we're gonna be
talking about you have a web app here
that you've written all this code for
and then you need to have a mobile app
that's pretty much the same thing but
you need to share that code who's ever
been in this experience that they've
written a web app and now then have a
report and it's like okay you want to
put the step almost the same code into a
mobile app and that's what we're going
to be talking about so but in particular
talking about if you have an ionic and
an angular app and how do you share code
between these two things
so I've had the chance to go do this for
a couple of customers last year worked
with a university where they wanted to
have these series of mobile apps for
doing navigation around the campus and
then also have some of that on a web app
and went and helped this school chain
back in Brisbane and one of the states
back home where they wanted to do a
similar thing it was mostly a mobile app
but they want to have a web version and
then again for this investment company
you already had the web app and then
they want to go to the mobile app and
what I've done with these people most of
the time is NPM packages which is one of
the things I'll talk about but since
leaving this other company I worked for
in doing all this consulting I'm now
working on another product that I own a
company called food zone now in the same
position where I've got to have a mobile
and a web app but the difference is now
I have to pull the dollars out of my own
pocket and put my money behind that
decision and I'm using the same tools
because I really love them
so it's a position that I find myself in
and in and I've had the chance to do a
fair bit of so we'll be sharing that
today and as I mentioned this is the way
I've been mostly doing it I would have
an NPM package and I'd put that shared
code in between the web and the mobile
because there's often a lot in these
kind of business line of application
style things that are similar between
the two so I'll be sticking them in an
NPM package but while I was doing all
these NPM packages I started to see kind
of a shift in a certain way people are
doing things and I started to people
talking about mono repos so this is a
blog from Alex Eagle on the angular team
and he's like you'll love mono repos too
and I'm starting to get more interested
about it so mono repo being the idea
that you might have multiple angular
applications in one repository and then
I see some of the most popular podcasts
so you've got like angular adventures in
angular and angular air talking about
this mono repo approach versus a mini
repo approach and the pros and cons and
all this time I'm writing all these NPM
packages for these other customers and
then I also find it really interesting
to hear that like Google and Facebook
also use a mono repo which is pretty
fascinating if you're an angular
developer on that on the angular team
and you change something it gets
committed to master every single angular
application at Google instantly get that
same version of that code so it's hard
to argue that a mono repo won't work but
I guess where this is leading is I'm
kind of hearing all about these mono
repos getting interested trying to solve
sharing code at work and then this tool
comes along cord now all extensions for
angular
in X so this is a way of doing a mono
repo with angular specifically for
angular so all of this is happening I'm
getting more interested in it over time
and that's kind of led me to the point
now where I'm like well there's kind of
two approaches you could either use NPM
packages or you could kind of have a
mono repo and rather than getting that
shared code between mobile and web into
a package that um came in so you could
just have it in the repository so I'm
gonna be talking mostly about these two
approaches and and what it looks like to
do that so we'll kick off talking a
little bit about the new angular and
ionic and there's a fair bit of changes
in that space coming we'll talk about
some of the code reuse options you have
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about energy rx and why I think it's one
of the most important parts if you're
going to get code reuse in your angular
applications because it's so great for
sucking logic out of your components and
then it makes it much easier to share
across components even if they're in
different applications then I'll talk
about that first main option which is
NPM packages and then talk about that
the other option which is NX mono repo
or you could do both so let's talk about
angular for a little bit I'm not gonna
bore you with too much of a background
with that angular who here has used
angularjs or the new angular before okay
a lot of people in the room so angularjs
is the first version everything from
angular 2 or further on they now just
call angular without the jas and its
goal is to be a superheroic javascript
framework but it had kind of problems
that was great like you know it had a
lot of adoption it solved a lot of our
problems but it was pretty slow when you
started to scale with it and this is
where the next version has kind of a
very lofty goal you can say this is
straight off their website today mobile
and desktop one framework so they're
very ambitious it's staying in this
space of being one framework mobile and
desktop and I really like angular for
lots of reasons I guess the biggest
reason it's a complete framework you're
gonna get component model dependency
injection routing testing
internationalization animation
accessibility testing twice and a
production build tour you get lots of
things out of the box in one spot but
there's more than that there's a whole
bunch of tools as well in the community
that angular either own or their big
part of so you've got Universal for
server-side rendering angular elements
we
just really exciting if you haven't seen
that that's the invader now for angular
for being able to do web components
which is kind of part of this code
sharing story so you can write web
components with angular and you could
put that on any site it doesn't have to
be an angular site you could put it on a
react site or just a straight vanilla
JavaScript web site there's pwace stuff
coming down the pipeline which is
amazing and now as of the last version
because we're currently at version 6
this week we've shifted about a week or
two ago from 5 to 6 you can just go ng
add progressive web app and it will set
you up an angular up as a progressive
web app so there's lots of this robust
nature coming into the framework now
there's ng rx which will talk a bunch
about for doing state management and
angular applications there's the angular
CLI which is like hugely popular and is
the main tool for making stuff and we'll
be talking about that there's material
for doing material components there's
the compel component dev kit which is a
way of being able to use all the logic
from material but without having the
styling from material and then you've
got animations and internationalization
basically this is one of the big draw
cards for me with angular as it's this
really robust tool chain that you can
use or framework it's easy to hire
people and it's very enterprise-e so
it's kind of you know a really appealing
offer and it keeps getting better I
really like this slide they showed this
off at ng-conf
two weeks ago so they've had this team
goal the the product manager for the
team would make them a cake if they got
under 10 kilobytes for a holo world so
this is kind of interesting that at the
moment version six they're at 36
kilobytes for a holo world which is
pretty impressive from where they've
come from it's getting smaller and
smaller all the time and now it would
the new things coming down the pipeline
like the IV render renderer which isn't
here yet they're going to have like a
minified then compressed version down to
like two kilobytes they were showing off
so it's cool it's constantly changing
it's all constantly kind of pushing the
boundaries which makes stuff tough for
us I'm sure a lot of you have felt kind
of the speed of change in this
environments quite fast and another you
know kind of an interesting part of this
story here is for us as a team we've
traditionally done lots of web
development but
you know as of 2016 was the first time
kind of the statistics show kind of a
crossing of paths where you're most of
the code that we write as developers
more of it's going to be used on a
mobile or a tablet versus being on a
desktop so no longer could we be like
mostly a webshop with a little bit of
mobile we now need to have lots of
mobile and lots of web and I'm sure a
lot of you are in a very similar
position what would love to have I'm
sure all of us would love to have this
is just native Android and native iOS
but that's pretty expensive yeah you
have to have two teams and you have to
have two code bases and then you have to
keep them in sync in the overhead so for
this reason we're seeing lots of
different options for trying to solve
this problem to write one code base for
mobile and then just compile down to
these two
nobody's solving it perfectly yet and
there's a fair few options on one front
you got xamarin and we've done several
xamarin apps in the company I was at
before but we found it was quite tough
we had to have kind of we couldn't just
drop a c-sharp dev straight on his
Ameren team and they would be effective
straightaway there was a fair bit of
ramp up for them but then the zamarons
stuff would be awesome but we kind of
wasn't working for us
flood is a new one who's heard of
flutter anybody heard of flutter well
Google has got a promote better so
flutter flutter is a tool a one-person
up the back photos float is a tool from
Google i/o is on right now they'll be
talking about it
they've been two years I think or
something with flutter so it's as
similar to xamarin you write dart code
which is pretty much a language that
comes from Google and then it will
compile down into native code that you
can run on Android and iOS if you
haven't seen it you should check it out
they're talking all about it for a fair
while now react native is another choice
if you're a react shocked then it's a
no-brainer this is a good choice and I
kind of have it a little bit to the
right because it's kind of not quite as
native as the ones on the left there's
still a little bit of overhead to it and
then there's native script so native
script is mostly angular based who's
used native script here okay who's used
ionic by the way okay maybe a third of
the room so native script is a really
good choice I haven't used that
professionally yet I find it kind of
interesting six months ago I would have
said ah I don't know if I'd trust using
it I don't know if it's going to go the
distance but now I'm seeing a lot of
I think it's not a bad choice but what
on the right here ionic is the one that
I'll be talking lots about and I kind of
have it on the right here because it's
more of the web they're kind of very web
focused versus being more sort of like
compiled down to native code so what is
ionic for those who haven't used it
ionic is basically an open source sdk
for building mobile apps and you this is
changing dramatically right now so at
the moment it's basically Cordova which
allows you to write HTML CSS and
JavaScript and then access the phone's
abilities like you know camera and
contacts and so forth so you use your
web skills and in particularly use your
angular web skills you write angular
code and it feels like writing an
angular app and then it compiles down to
go on the device and this is currently
how it works but this is really changing
a lot and it's really exciting so what's
happening now ionic team I don't know
it's pretty crazy how ambitious I think
they're trying to be but they're writing
this a replacement called capacitor for
cutover
so that's the thing that will manage
dealing with the device and they're now
saying our framework whatever you can
turn up with angular you can turn up
with view and you can turn up with
stencil
they've also rewritten all their stuff
as stents always a web components it's
the ionic web components so they're very
written this like web based system now
they're really pushing towards web and
this changes how we can share code
because things are getting there they're
trying to make this experience where you
just write for the web and then it will
just work on a mobile but we're not
quite there yet
this is coming down the pipeline so
ionic one was pretty slow that was one
of its biggest problems million apps
built sort of thing on it they got huge
adoption and ionic 3 has been much
better for us to be much faster it's
written on the new framework angular 2
which has been good for us or angular 2
or higher and then angular on ik 4 is
going to be much much faster supposedly
like all the parts of it have been
changed so that's going to be pretty
exciting but I think the thing that
really like about ionic is just how easy
it is for us to take an angular
developer and get them effective at
riding a mobile app so quickly you
basically can come in and say oh an X
start give you a project a name and then
you can say what type oh let's have tabs
on the bottom and then you can just see
it into your project and say
you don't need an emulator or run in the
browser and you can just get going
really quickly and if you want to build
it and deploy it then pretty much you
just can go I on it Cordova run -
Android - - release and you're away and
now the whole there's so much - ionic
there's I'm not going to go through all
of it they've got a whole ionic proto
kit they keep working on so that you can
you know go from design all the way to
you know building it online so that you
can get the IP K or the apk to actually
deploy and it's quite a robust system
coming down the other thing that I
really like and this is related to
sharing code here is that you end up
getting this set of components with
ionic so and I really love them because
when I first started using I was like
wow these are better than all the other
web components are used from kendo or
other people they're they just seem to
work but the problem with these widgets
like a slider and a drop-down that they
have at the moment is they're not
designed to run in the browser they're
designed to run on the device they're
optimized for touch and all those sorts
of things so it's very very rare to see
someone try and take these components or
widgets and use them on a web app so you
end up in this position where you've got
some use on the mobile app and a whole
nother set that you use on your web when
you're trying to share code you can do
Windows but I'm not sure what's
happening in this space very rare I
think of I think Microsoft is the only
person I know has ever deployed an ionic
app with Windows Phone once okay I've
got a stencil compiler who's heard of
stencil okay one person so not many so
there's a whole bunch of stuff you're
gonna see coming down the pipeline for
ionic across multiple frameworks it's
going to be bigger for view and for
angular so stencil is a set of web
components based on the web components
standard so they don't need to run in a
framework you can drop them on any
website and they'll run they're
self-contained following a standard so
if they and they've gone and replaced
and soon with ionic for all of their all
of the widgets that you get from ionic
will run perfect just as well on a web
app as they will on a mobile app so the
code sharing story is going to get
better suspense was worth looking out
for
oh just go back a step there so ionic is
really interesting to watch if you're
betting on ionic at the moment and
you're building apps with ionic they're
a person to watch because they're
changing dramatically I kind of watch
and go I hope they pull it off because
you know I've got all these apps in it
and other sorts of things and this is
one of their mottos target the web where
or wherever it runs and another one of
their mottos is kind of along the lines
of like you know web first that's what
they're really focused on where are
these other people trying to solve this
problem of one code base are really
trying to go down to a native kind of
experience so it's an interest
interesting approach that they're taking
so that's just a little bit talking
about what's coming down and and how
that kind of affects us a little bit but
I want to jump into talking about like
what are your options for code reuse
good and bad and in particular when we
have this an angular app we've got
components we got routing we got
services we've got state these sorts of
things that we could share with another
application and in a mobile app it's
pretty similar when you're using ionic
that is but what parts of these can we
share at the moment well at the moment
it's very easy to share an angular
service because it's just a typescript
class that's very easy to share State if
you using ng rx which we'll get to
but components are a bit trickier
because of what I said like the
components with a HTML and the widgets
on them
I want to write mine with the
best-of-breed ionic stuff at the moment
for the ionic and I want to use angular
material in my web app because they're
the best ones for the web stuff but they
don't kind of cross over very well to
use on both so if you've got your own
custom ones then yeah of course you can
write your own components and then it
will work but for us what we've been
doing is drawing a line there and saying
we're going to share all of the kind of
logic on our client-side but our
components we're not going to really try
and share yet but in the future I hope
this will be part of where we're heading
so copy and paste not so good huh I
think we've all got an experience going
I've got this logic that I've written
over in this app and now you need to
share it to another app and then it's
only a short period of time until
someone comes up to you and goes can you
read the commits from the other app and
make sure that they're the same and then
this just goes round and round so copy
and paste is never really going to work
in this situation unless it's a tiny bit
of code reuse putting them in a folder
is also not going to work for angular
very well
angular needs a build tool
to compile it it has a whole build
system around it so I've seen people do
this but it never works out very well
even just getting it from type the
typescript compilation and so forth so
if you stick it in just a folder that
lives there and it's outside of that
build chain if it as a sub module or
something it's not the most robust
method it's not going to work so well it
seems easy at first but you probably
worth spending a bit more time to do one
of these other options different to
those sorts of things about sharing like
everything in terms of code is a tool
called n swag so who's who's heard of
swagger here who's using swagger to
document their API fair few people so
maybe more than half so swag is an
awesome tool and what you can do with
swagger when you document your back end
your API when you've got all these DT OS
and view models back there you need
those same things in typescript on the
client side because you're going to say
when I make my page CTP request to get
this entity from my back-end I now need
to have a typescript interface on my
client side that describes the shape of
that object coming down so what we've
used is a tool called n swag the first
time I saw this I thought this is never
going to work well we're going to
auto-generate
all kind of typescript interfaces for
our angular app I'm not a fan of this
idea but we've done it in five different
apps that's worked at every time it's
been brilliant
so I'm actually quite surprised how well
it turns out but that's only sharing the
code to save you writing those
interfaces but it's quite good because
as soon as you change your back-end all
of your interfaces on your client-side
you just run a little script and it
updates all that so that's quite a
fantastic tool for code when you spit
that it's a bit different type of code
reuse that I'm kind of talking about
here but I thought I'd throw it in so we
have this core and I want to try and get
as much in there so we've been using NPM
packages and I think this is probably
the most robust version for being able
to do this and what we've done a lot but
I also like this monitor of a repo
approach which we'll talk about okay but
if you're going to do this it's
important to remember wherever you put
this shared code it needs to be angular
eyes it needs to have some sort of build
chain for this to work well so here in
the in this case I need to follow the
angular package format it's actually a
thing you can go get the document and
read it and it will suggest for you it's
about 20 pages long what are all the
things you need to do as an angular
developer to make sure that the code or
library you're writing for
angular beer to be used on a mobile or
web is angular iced so you're going to
need to go make a core metadata JSON
files that you can run a ot so äôt is
this ahead of time compilation so that
you compile all of your angular HTML
templates which have angular like syntax
on them like an NG if down to being
executable code you're going to need to
have all your DTS file so you've got
typescript definitions you're going to
need to have courgettes this flattened
ACMA script module which has a great
name of phezzan so if you load hundreds
of modules into the browser JavaScript
modules that can slow things down so
when you actually put it there you want
to bring them all back into one module
and that'll speed things up and then
you've got a you might want to have a
UMD file you might want to be closure
compiler compatible so that in the
future if closure becomes another
compiler angular used to crush down the
project's then you're ready for that I
don't want to do any of this honestly I
don't want to even look at this I just
want to write angular code and have it
work
and I bet you most of you are the same
so it's a bit too complex to roll your
own one of these you're going to need a
library for it so that's a bit of a
takeaway from this if you're gonna write
an angular library beer to share or just
using one app you're gonna need to
follow these things so there's a bunch
of different ways a bunch of different
libraries I'll show you that you have
choices on what you can do with that
coming up but before we do I wanted to I
wanted to jump forward and talk about ng
rx because for us in this story of
sharing code and jerax has been a real
key to it not just for making our
applications more robust and making them
less buggy but it's been really
important because it helps suck kind of
the logic out of your components and be
able to put it in this shareable space
so who's heard of redux here okay who's
using ng Eric's or redux okay so maybe a
fifth of the room okay so ng rx or is
the way that you do the Redux pattern
for angular so redux is a pattern it's
also a library from the react community
there's also a similar version in view
they've got Bewkes but in angular we use
this thing called ngrick so it's much
bigger than angular this Redux thing but
if you want to implement that pattern in
angular you use ng rx a little different
in
because we use rxjs or reactive
extensions for JavaScript which is
observables if you're doing angular a
lot of you'll be aware of it but this is
kind of a bit of a twist on it so it's
really good as I said because it it
helps us suck this logic out of our
components and I'll show you some
examples of that so what's the best way
to kind of share state in an angular
application at the moment if you're not
going to use ng X so this would be best
practice if you've got a smaller app and
you don't want to use ng X you would
follow this pattern of having like a
container a component which is also some
people call a smart component and then a
presentation or component and the
container component would be the smart
one presentation or component would be
the dumb one and then the way that you
would check share between these two s or
communicate is with these inputs or
outputs so the container components the
one that's going to have the injected
dependencies it's the note1 who knows
how to route it knows how to delete an
entity do all the work but it doesn't
really deal with rendering the HTML and
actually showing the buttons and doing
all the kind of the UI pieces that would
be the job of the presentational
component but what happens when you kind
of get these nested presentational
components and you're communicating
between them with inputs and outputs if
you go to too many deep then you've got
to communicate you've got to pass it up
a level an event through this app output
and upper level and upper level and then
when you get another component that's
way off in your component tree and
angular then it's going to get harder to
communicate so what most people do is
best practice they go well let's make
this a container component let's inject
the service and we'll put this logic or
state that I need between these two
sections of my app share it through a
service and this works great but as your
application starts to grow and you get
more services and more components on the
page and these components are talking
with these services and these services
and these services gets very hard to
know who updated which state in which
service at what time and you start
getting race conditions and other
challenges so this is where using
something like an jerax that uses redux
and has a store a single place to put
all that shared state can really help
and this has been quite useful for
sharing code across apps
so I want to just take a minute some of
you would have seen this and get this
very clearly used it but I was take a
minute to do a lap through like what is
the pattern what is Redux and and what's
that mean for us to be out of share code
so one of the main principles is this
idea that you have a store so you store
as just a JavaScript object it looks
like this here with you can see we've
got companies and contacts but it's
literally just a JavaScript object and
when I want to get information out of
the store then I would into a component
I'll use what's called a selector and
that selector will be an observable and
if this component wanted to get the list
of companies it would select those
companies out of the store and then I
have it in the component and what I
would normally do in an in an on njx app
if I wanted to delete one of these
companies I'll just right there in the
component I would use an angular I'll
talk to an angular service it would talk
to the API delete the company API would
come back successfully to their service
talk to the component and right there in
the component I'll do a bunch of work
I'd actually take that array of
companies and delete it out delete the
one I want to get rid of and then just
update the UI but that's not how you do
it in a ng rx app now the component
doesn't know how to do all that stuff
and that's good because we can start
removing you know making these more
reusable so the component if it wants to
delete a company now would need to
dispatch an action it's quite a specific
time and the actions look like this they
have a type and a payload so the type
here is delete company and the payload
would be the ID of the company and who's
listening for this event or this action
that you've raised well there's two
spots one of the spots would be reducers
and the other spots going to be effects
and effects come from the library this
effects library from ng rx and in our
case here we're making a HTTP request to
the latest company so if it was a if it
was a synchronous amount of work that I
need to do and it was going to be I
could do it in a pure function then I'll
just go straight to the reducer and a
pure function being one that you know
you call with the same arguments every
time will give you the same result but
at HTTP a request to a back-end you
don't know what's going to happen it's
very asynchronous it could be a 500 so
in that case you're going to go through
the effect talk with your angular
service it will go call you back and
delete the company if it's successful or
come back to the
the job of the effect is then to
dispatch another action in this case it
would be the delete company success and
the ID of the company to delete at this
point we are in a synchronous amount of
the work we need to do a synchronous and
we can do it in a pure function so we'll
do it in the reducer and we'll take this
action and the current state make new
State for the companies and that will
update the store so this one-way cycle
of flow not only helps your applications
be really robust but it's that's
detaching this logic from the components
in your application and makes it more
shareable which is kind of a side effect
the main benefit of NGO X and redux is
writing more scalable less buggy code so
this is kind of what it looks like for
those who haven't seen it you just
inject the store into a into a component
and then you might have something like
this login function and this component
now doesn't know how to do anything it
doesn't know how to delete companies all
it knows how to do is just say hey can
you dispatch as an action to login or
not delete but in this case login so it
just goes hey I want to login here's the
payload which has the username and
password can somebody go do it
so this components really simple now it
doesn't have to do all that work doesn't
really know much about anything and the
logic to do that work is easily pushed
out shared elsewhere so when I want to
use this all I have to do is inject the
store into another component and then I
want to get this user then I just use
the store again to select and I've got a
custom selector here of get user that
you could write and then I have an
observable of that user so in this case
you can see how it really cleans up your
components and makes things a lot
simpler have a whole play-by-play on
this I think Lars is next door you can
go watch that if you want to see kind of
if you're new to redux and in Jarek so
you can go watch it so that's just a
little introduction because that's been
a really big part for us like we've
spent a whole bunch of time getting up
skilled with ngrick s-- and a big side
benefit of that is being able to share
code because it all lives in this system
Avenger X and we can just use it the
whole thing in another application okay
so moving on to talk about these two
options and what are the options we have
here so the first one is NPM packages
I have a whole nother play-by-play on
this someone asked me am I going to do a
live code demo if you really want to
watch a full live code demo you can just
go watch either of those and there's
lots in there about it alright so I want
to I want to be able to do this I want
to make an NPM package with all of my
angular services all my redux stuff so
that when I have my web app I write all
my stuff for my login so you can
dispatch in action to log in it calls
the service logs the mean gets the Tok
and all that sort of stuff but when I
are at my mobile app I just want to use
the exact same logic again so I can put
all that in these services in this state
management go and use that so the way
we've been doing it with is changing so
this is how I've done it several times I
use this library here called generator
angular 2 library so it's a community
project
it's got three hundred stars here on
this picture it's probably more up to a
thousand now it's a bit old this picture
but this library is really good because
you don't have to go do all that work
that I showed you to kind of be angular
eyes your shareable stuff so the way it
works you install this yeoman generator
you basically say hey yo I want to make
an angular 2 library and it will talk
you through it you say here's my name
and my email at the library name I want
to use gesture Karma choose your testing
framework and boom it makes you a
separate repository that's just for this
section of code that you want to share
and inside of here you'll have all the
bits it kind of looks like an angular
app but it's just one little part and
there's lots to it but we're not going
to go through all of it but the bulk of
it you'll get and this is similar for
the other ones that I'll show you you're
going to get a whole bunch of sample
stuff in there you can see we've got a
sample component sample directive pipe
but the interesting thing here is this
index TS file so basically you write
some angular code it's going to feel
just like writing normal angular code as
I'll show you and then in here in this
index dot TS file or in this barrel you
look at sky NICAP ublic api of this set
of code that you have so there's lots in
there but these are the bits I want
people to be able to see so your
document in your index dot ES file and
say these are the bits that people can
access from here I'm going to export
them out and often that looks like this
just looks like an angular module so if
you've done any angular 2 or higher
you'll be very
with this angular modules are the all
over your application its way the way
you say for this section of code these
are the things or dependencies for this
area so here you can see I'm going to
export out of this module this angular
module and it feels just like
bread-and-butter angular but we're in an
NPM package so this is the component
that I want to share out and this is a
service that I want the consuming
application to register for me so I've
got it in this for root method so it's
pretty simple it doesn't feel too
different to writing your angular stuff
but the whole build chains a bit of a
pain in the butt and I'll talk more
about it so we don't want to use that
imagine there was you know from here on
this is your job the developers job to
go write the bits that you want I'm
going to write the function that takes
the user name and password and logs in
and so forth and do the work in the
service but when you have your consuming
application it feels very much just like
using a third-party library you
basically just go I've written my own
sample module it's inside my NPM package
so NPM install my at sample - package
and then I can just go slash core and
pull out the sample module and then I
just have down here I import it into the
consuming applications angular module
sample module dot for route so if you've
written NPM packages for Angela this
will feel very familiar but if you've
just worked in angular this will look
like you're importing someone else's
third-party library except you wrote it
so how do you actually use this and this
is one of the challenges we've found
with NPM that costs us time and costs
the team's time is you've got this thing
called NPM link because as a developer
you're sitting at your desk
you've got application one over here
application two over here imagine you're
in your machine and then you've got your
NPM package they're all separate you're
on your device you don't want to have to
change one line of this shared code and
and then push it up into you know
whatever's hosting this shared package
and then npm install it down into the
other things just to see if it works and
then change one more line and then have
to do that same process again and again
so the way you get around it is you can
do an NPM link so NPM link comes from
you know and if you've got node
installed and you know
package manager then all this will be
sitting on your machine so if you're at
the path in the command line of the
shared project that you've got you can
basically just say NPM link and then CD
into the application that's you want to
share it with and run an NPM link my -
shared code or whatever the name of your
shared package is and then it's kind of
synced up so if I make a change in one
as long as the build tools running in my
NPM package on my machine then I can
instantly use it over in the consuming
application on my machine and that
speeds things up you don't have to leave
your development environment to get it
going but I found this a real pain in
the butt it's kind of flaky it's not
necessarily the best way of doing things
it's not Lissa's it's not flawless and
it's one of the trickier parts and this
is even before you try and share it with
another developer because it's a
completely separate environment but it
works okay
but then you get to the point you got to
NPM install it so what are you going to
do there if it with your team you've got
a couple of different options so you've
written it it's working it's tested you
know it's doing its job but now you need
to kind of put it in production so you
could use a hosted package manager like
NPM and pay for it that's a super simple
option they've got private hosted so you
can have a private NPM package and
there's a robust ecosystem for it you
can use a private one like vedecci oh
and I've worked with a couple of
companies who do this he hosts it
yourself so it's like hosting your own
NPM repository and that works quite well
as well and for a lot of corporate
clients that's their only choice because
they're not going to use NPM so that
they're both the most popular ones
you can do this funky thing here that
I'm showing you but it will probably
come back and just be a pain so another
really fast way of just being able to
share it is you could actually just NPM
install it from a link so you could put
this in your package JSON file and it
will install this from whatever link
your repository is at but if this is
private then this becomes really painful
really fast because you've got to have
the password and so forth for this and
how do you get it into the insert this
kind of setup here
so it's not kind of very good I find to
do this unless it's super easy or you're
just getting going but it is one option
so NPM packages are great I like I think
I don't think I'm gonna stand up here
and say it's not what you should do like
there's definitely a huge place for them
it's the primary way of sharing code in
the JavaScript world but I've found for
angular its it can be quite painful and
for a couple of different reasons but
let's run through some of the positives
the really big positive it's versioned
so you can have version one that one
teams on in version 1.1 which the next
teams on and the two teams don't have to
stay directly in sync so that's a big
deal for a lot of people and you if
you've got stable code I love MPN
packages for that if your codes not
changing very much that much that whole
story of publishing it and then other
people consuming it and then if
something needs to be changed quickly
and quickly and quickly going through
that same process if it's something
stable let's say your company's written
some widget like a menu bar and hasn't
changed in I don't know three months
then that's a great thing to put in an
NPM package because you're not going to
have to go through that cycle all the
time but if it's like your core business
logic that's always iterating or you're
at the beginning of a project it's a
real pain to go through that so stable
code is a great place for it so it might
start off in this mono repo situation
I'll talk about and then move to an NPM
package and also if it needs to be
public so if you have code that you have
been a private repository and you want
to share it with someone else that's
going to be really difficult cuz I'm
going to talk about just having a
repository and not publishing it to NPM
so if it needs to be public then an NPM
package can be good for that you can
just share this single piece of shared
stuff publicly and other stuff can be
private but some of the things I don't
like about this prototype painful as you
start to do it is that it needs a lot
more testing because you're writing this
in isolation you don't know when the
downstream when the application consumes
your NPM package if it's going to work
so you need to be better at testing and
you need to you can't throw junk over
the fence because you don't know what
happens when they install it whereas if
you actually run it inside the same
repository as I show you then
potentially there's some other benefits
to to not having to worry as much it
takes a fair bit of time to configure
this approach not so much to configure
it I think once you're up and running
it's not so bad but what
like several teams do this approach from
scratch and they're not used to doing
NPM packages they'll usually one
developer is going to burn a week
wrapping their head around it and kind
of getting all the bits in place and
then the rest of the team can kind of
watch and get up to speed so it's not
too expensive but it definitely has a
bit of a cost you know if you've got a
two-month turnaround it's probably not
the greatest option to do unless you're
already used to making NPM packages an
IOT sucks just yeah this ahead of time
compilation where you pre compile your
angular templates if you're working in
this separate silo where you're making
this NPM package it's working great on
your machine and then all of a sudden
you're doing lots of stuff in there but
you haven't run a OT in a while because
that's normally something people forget
to run until they actually go to publish
it so you might have gone a day or two
days and you haven't run a OTE sort of
build on it and then it breaks because
of IOT and then you're like ah what did
I do in the last two days that that's
now causing it to break and some of that
debugging experience has been more
painful you know running these packages
versus a normal angular app and a IOT so
for me I just leave a ot on all the time
when I'm making these shared packages I
just put the flag on the back of the
build command so this is all changing
like I said I'm going to share with you
all the stuff that's changing in the
community so this is how I've been doing
it this is how a lot of people are doing
it that library is still really vibrant
but there's been a nother library for
doing packages that's getting a lot of
traction called ng packager and it's
written by one of the people who are on
the angular team which is pretty good
credentials and this is getting way more
popular now so much so that as a version
6 of the angular CLI now you can
actually make a library right here in
your project so who's using angular 6 in
production okay the hands went down so
last week angular 6 came out and it's a
it hardly changes much of the code you
write but it's really cool all the stuff
that's coming for making our lives
easier to build an application and to do
libraries so one of the things that
they've released is this idea of being
able to do more than one angular
application in an angular CLI project so
you can make a projects folder or
scaffold it out
you could have two apps in there so you
could say I'm gonna have app 1 and app 2
but what's really cool now is you can
use ng packager the other library for
making NPM packages and you can just
scaffold it straight out in the same
repository and the same tools that you
used to so this has only just come out
you won't see great Doc's about it yet
you won't see many people using it yet
even though lots of people are using ng
packager but this is going to become the
default I think because we all just
follow the CLI it's so amazing the
angular CLI so if you wanted to do an
NPM package you'll find that this is
likely the approach that you want to be
looking into doing so same things that I
showed you before but you'll use the CLI
on you just say ng library give it a
name and or put it in here and the whole
build tool around it will be in here
which is pretty cool I think it's
awesome there's some pretty excited
people out there about it ok so that's
for doing an NPM package totally nothing
wrong with it
but I found this cycle kind of painful
to go through using NPM packages because
the code changes a lot and the things
I'm sharing a really day-to-day angular
code services and so forth so that's
when we've started using NX n x mono
repo so the current project I'm on we've
got about three devs on it's not a
massive project we kicked off at the end
of last year and we started it as an NX
mono repo so the NX mono repo sounds
like it's a whole new thing it's not
really that big a thing and I'll tell
you why but basically it's now all
extensions for angular so now all is a
company that have written these
extensions and that's all they are
but now we'll a pretty interesting group
they're our team of consultants you can
hire them here in North America they're
about more than a dozen of them now and
Victor and Jeff who you can see in this
picture used to be on the angular team
they wrote some of the things like the
router and dependency injection and they
pride themselves on hiring consultants
who are pretty badass so there that's
their kind of niche and of course they
used to write lots of libraries at
Google yeah they wrote the framework and
had to share it with all of us so when
they left there and started doing
enterprise consulting they're like well
we do libraries all the time and we work
in Google's mono repo we want the same
thing for our enterprise clients because
that's who they
a focus on so they went and wrote these
now all extensions and really all now
all extensions are as angular schematics
which is a way of extending the CLI so
all it is is an extension of the angular
CLI it's not some massive thing but it
helps a lot in scaffolding applications
but it's very opinionated you know
they've got we think that you should
build enterprise applications like this
so you get a lot of things out of the
box in terms of linting and formatting
knowing what applications have changed
scaffolding out multiple applications so
we were like we're not going to do NP n
packages for showing between our mobile
and web app we're going to use NX and
that's what we're going to stick all of
our state management and our lives in so
if you're going to do NX you'd end up in
a position like this so I've got a
sample web in the orange and I got a
sample mobile in the blue here two
separate applications not many people
are doing this with mobile I'll be
honest I'm kind of fringing early in
this space but there's others I'll talk
about that but their main motto that NXT
most of the people using NX are doing
this just with multiple web applications
but we've been doing it with mobile so
imagine I have this sample web app in
orange and it might have its own libs
and this language is specific to NX you
go apps which are applications and libs
which are libraries and you make an app
and then a bunch of libs and then you
pull those libs into the app to compose
up your application so here I might have
a layout Lib that's specific just for
this sample web application and then I
might have some other libs that are
specific just for this mobile
application like layout and something to
do with photos for the camera on the
phone but then I might have a whole
bunch of other libs that I want to share
across both these applications so I make
more libs
and then those libs can be shared across
both so end up namespacing them in
folders in this similar sort of way so
if you want to make one of these it's
just an extension of the angular CLI you
go install NPM install the angular CLI
on your machine and then you install the
angular the narwhals schematics and
you're ready to go so once you've
installed the schematics you just go
create NX workspace and give it a name
and boom it makes you very something
very similar to the angular CLI but the
big difference
is on an angular CLI app you'll just
have one application on the route I
showed you that projects folder before
with the stuff that's new for the CLI
where you had multiple apps in a library
but you've got to go and still do a
bunch of stuff to make that happen
whereas here it just that's their focus
so when you have both of these the
mobile app becomes a challenge because
that's what we're talking about today
and this was one of the first hurdles we
hit in this is well where do we stick
our mobile apps because they're not
really an egg they're an angular app but
the build tools different and it
actually doesn't share the package.json
and all the other dependency of our web
apps because ionics really specific
about how it builds it needs to have
this you know node modules folder inside
of this folder and the build tools are
at this file path and we didn't want to
go playing around with all that so we
just put the whole ionic app and all of
its build stuff and it's node modules
and everything straight in this mobile
app folder here so if you expose out
this libs folder you end up in a
situation like this where you have like
sample app one folder with the stuff
that's just the sample app one a shared
folder for all the things that are
shared and then a state folder for all
the things that a state-based and Eric's
state-based
so if you want to have you know all the
authentication state the core state the
search state all of those things would
put in here so this is the approach
we've gone down if you're just writing
to two web applications within X you
might not necessarily want to do that
but in our case we wanted to separate
the UI out from the NX from the NGO X
parts we wanted to say all of our state
logic we want to completely separate it
from the HTML so that way we can share
it with the mobile and the web but if
you're doing this with just two web apps
you might put all that state stuff
inside the shared thing okay so this is
actually our application at the moment
it's a little bit small there but
basically in our apps folder we've got a
food zone - app and a food zone - public
app so we've got a public site web site
and then we have a public app it's still
pretty small we're only a few people a
few months or probably five months in
and then down here we have our lives and
we've learnt to namespace these libs at
first we just stuck them
all straight in this folder and we ended
up with 50 of them straight away and it
got a mess so then we namespace them
back down so we've got third zone -
Edmund - app so we've got an admins like
a heavy admin section and then the rest
of the app and then we've got a shared
section and a state folder so that's
kind of the approach there's a bunch
more in this I'm not showing you around
some of these challenges because even
though this state thing we've kept
agnostic from HTML and these shared
components it's been a little tricky
because when you're inside the middle of
doing some work with ng rx you'll often
say okay great I've I've deleted this
user and now I've updated my state but
now I want to stop a spinner or I want
to show a spinner and that spinner is
going to be a different spinner on
mobile and web so we've been using
dependency injection quite heavily to
inject like at runtime inject in those
UI pieces into this section to share as
well if you're interested come find me
I'll show you what we did but there is a
little bit more tricky nough sin to it
but it's but it's been much easier story
than writing NPM packages because all
this codes churning all the time you
know it's just that core stuff that
you're right okay and then we've got our
mobile app down underneath here there's
also other apps in here for databases
and functions and we've got an importer
app a bunch of other node apps but when
you're writing it when you're writing an
application within X some people have
been like oh it's a mono rip I have to
put everything my back-end in there and
all of my company's stuff we're never
going to be able to do it but that's not
the case you could just use an X to do a
single application that's story of
breaking things out into libs and then
your component your application is just
a shell that you put libs into there's a
really nice story for angular
development the architecture is great so
that can work quite well or you might
have two of your applications in your
company you want to put in a mono repo
but your other three aren't related they
don't share much code so I won't put
them in the same repo it's all up to you
as the developer how big these mono
repos get
two weeks ago at ng-conf friends of mine
Jeff and Nathan released this tool
called ex Platt which I think's really
exciting and it's also the first kind of
thing I've seen anybody do in this space
that I'm talking about with an ex so
they love in Ex as well and I remember
we jumped on a phone call together where
I saw and they'll getting this started
but they really love native script I
really love ionic but they've gone and
made actually a tool that sits on top of
their necks the community tool called
explant that allows you to run native
script server-side rendering a web app
with all the best SEO strategies and
everything so rather than rolling your
own of all these if you're going to use
NX and try and share code between mobile
and web if you're using native scripts
I'd recommend checking this out because
it looks amazing but I'm not really
stuck to ionic and I'm not really stuck
I haven't used native scripts but if I
was starting a new project what if this
got traction I'd be very interested in
having a look at it it's very early days
like all of us developers you know
you've got to do due diligence there's a
lot of the stuff we use burns out really
quick huh and you've got to protect
yourself from that but this looks really
awesome they've done an amazing job it's
worth checking out okay so what are the
things that I really love about a mono
repo I love how fast it is to get
started you just start like the angular
CLI on your away by default you
everything's pulled out of the app
you're building it to share it's really
good so sharing becomes much easier you
don't have this n chem install this NPM
linking and all those sorts of things
we're still going to end up with NPM
packages but most of it will be just
directly shared through the repository
shared dependencies is a positive and a
negative in this space
this is if you've got everything in one
mono repo for these angular apps and
you're going to share code between them
you're sharing the same load modules and
the same package to Jason and the same
versions of everything so depending on
your team and the size of your company
that might be unrealistic so I've worked
with government teams in Australia where
they've got you know 20 different teams
they're like we could but it's almond
Tevan imagine how we could all be on the
same version our culture isn't that
culture we've had a life of going
projects that are always at different
versions of all these things so for them
they wouldn't be able to do it but for a
lot of people it is achievable and a lot
of big companies like Google and
Facebook do do that so having every
single app on the same version of
typescript you know you're committing to
doing that and this in you your build
process is going to be gonna cost you
more time because when you build this
NPM package before you just build this
little thing it's really quick it just
builds then you're done it's not got
much to build but now you're going to
build that all of these apps this mobile
app and potentially in our case we're
building some back-end stuff as well and
that takes us at the moment not too long
it's about 10 minutes to four hour build
step which is not too bad we can live
with that but as we get more tests and
more end-to-end tests that'll probably
go up to 20 minutes pretty quickly and
then we'll probably have to optimize but
we might get away with never having to
actually start getting to the point
where we go what actually changed and
let's only rebuild the things that
changed but there is some stuff in NX
which is pretty cool to go read through
the commits and go okay great we'll give
you the tooling to know which apps are
affected by these changes and which ones
you need to rebuild we haven't had to
use them yet but that's there so that's
kind of a pro and a con in one way it's
easier for us because we've just got one
build script we just run the whole world
every time we build all of our stuff
everyone and I sleep a little better for
that because if I broke something in
this shared thing it's not going to run
when I run my tests in my actual
consuming application at the exact same
time and that's I like that I like that
it's going to break so that's kind of a
pro and a con there but as you get up if
you had 40 team members you're going to
have to probably have some custom
sophisticated thing to to know which
things to rebuild because it will slow
down too much so where are we going to
go to from here what do I think is going
to happen in this space well I kind of
already highlighted some of the things
that I think we're gonna see I think I'm
fingers crossed I'm hoping this is the
year we see web components become
day-to-day for us I'd love to see the
stencil components from the ionic team
but can't become something that I can
use in a web app and I'd love to see
angular elements that sin beta become
something I can use in a mobile app and
then I'd love to use those components in
something that's not even an angular app
so at that point I could probably start
to share a lot more code in these
applications because my table component
that shows a list of users is going to
be the same one in mobile and web but
we're not quite there yet and even
though it's probably going to come out
for ionic next month it's probably going
to be months after that until we're
actually at a point where we're ready to
use it or it's not it's actually going
to be in our C or something else it'll
still be beta so that's a bit of a ways
off the other thing I really think
that's going to happen at the end of
this year is I think NX caused this
movement change and now we're seeing
angular CLI support libraries and
multiple applications but they're doing
it slightly different and they're not
quite communicating yet because it's the
beginning for both of them they are
communicating but I think we're going to
see lots of these tools and we see
explant come out that sits on top of n X
I think we're gonna see all of this kind
of gel to be a community one that we all
use like the CLI and it's going to be
like butter it'll be much easier you'll
just go give me a new project and
another new project and a library and I
want it all to work and I don't want to
have to make all these decisions that we
had to make so I think that's where
we'll be at the end of the year but
right now it's kind of early days for
all the things we're looking at and
using I'm gonna be in NDC Oslo in June I
think it's probably the most fun
conference I've ever been to if you ever
get a chance to go we're gonna run a two
day workshop I was just here running a
two day workshop on in X and angular and
all the things I was talking about
except the mobile side so if you're
interested in coming along come join us
so what have we what are we talked about
today well we had a look at the new
angular and that's not so new but the
ionic stuff's changing a lot we had a
look at some good and bad code reuse
options we looked at how ng rx can
really help like pulling that code out
of the components and making it more
reusable we had a look at NPM packages
and why that's a great option and why
sometimes it's not a great option and we
looked at NX mono repos and that kind of
movement that's coming into angular and
some of the benefits around it so thank
you very much guys
I'll be around if anyone has any
questions
[Applause]
test yeah that's really good great
I'm going to clip it or put it in my
pocket or okay yeah